I was one of the first people in my
platoon that actually got sent to
Afghanistan a grenade detonated next to
me and the people I was with and I
remember distinctly thinking please let
the grenade detonate below my head so
that it'll kill me but it won't blow my
head off and that at least my family
will be able to identify me again this
happened in like a split second but it's
like it hits my shoulder and then it
fell down towards the ground and as it
followed down my body I'm like okay good
maybe it'll hit my legs and it'll just
take my legs out hits the ground it
detonated and it just felt like someone
took a big handful of box and just like
threw it at the back of my legs and my
back I was basically down on the ground
bleeding to death and my medic who's
also a seal he was the only guy who was
not directly injured by the frag of the
grenade he was concussed he literally
saved my life he dragged me to cover as
much as we could and he literally laid
over me and put my tourniquet on and he
was like so calm you know he's like hey
it's going to be fine like literally R
was trained for it crazy